taylor is in houston texas hey taylor
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call today sure
what's up
uh yes so my husband and i are in baby
step two
so we started in september of this year
we've paid off about six grand or so
so yeah and so the next question is we
still have a lot of debt to go but we
know we need to get rid
of one of our vehicles that we are
upside down on
uh my question is how to best go about
that so we're probably about
40 4 500 4 000 upside down
due to a private or to a private self so
do i
put that money towards just principal
payments or do i say that
into savings until it's time to sell and
then apply it to the loan or does it not
really matter
doesn't matter either one's fine and i
would count that
if you if that's a car you're selling i
would take 4500 upside down amount
put that number in your debt snowball
okay so just put that in the notes so i
can pay
so okay so putting in the snowball so we
have that
smaller than that at this point so
should we just um
we have a few credit cards that are
below that amount yeah
you'll knock them out before you do this
car deal probably okay
and then i would knock out the card then
i would knock out the car save up the
five grand to get out of the car right
or pay it down five grand either one get
rid of the car and of course you got to
get your little beater car to get around
in too right
yeah well we're just going to go one car
because he gets a work truck so i work
from home
like yeah he can just take my car to get
there if he needs to
okay that makes me feel better because
putting that money in savings kind of
scares me because art doesn't really
scare me i'm like ooh i could apply this
here because we've gone super crazy
we're doing uber east and we're doing
all of that fun stuff
so we're really excited but it's really
scary just to put that money aside and
then apply it all at the end
yeah you're doing so good yeah you guys
are doing a great job yeah keep working
your debt snowball
like keep that money as it comes in keep
it moving directly toward the debt
everything but a thousand dollars
and what that's going to do is help you
stay on the path so taylor proud of you
all
this is the time of year don't let your
guard down stupid is lurking around
every corner so be intentional
yeah um i've also noticed you can't let
your guard down on food this time of
year
food and money why you had to get all
churches and broke sudden you had to get
your time here ramsay
i went to meddling then yeah i'm i'm on
salads right now
which is frustrating because salad isn't
the food salad is a promissory note
like more food is coming and so i'm i'm
having to adjust my mindset
especially if you're from the south
where your salads are so you put gravy
on salad in the south